Jake: 还没解封
Jake: The lockdown wasn’t lifted yet.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 所以就是我当时被相当于封在上海
Lucia: So I was basically stuck in Shanghai.
Lucia: 去不了别的地方一段时间
Lucia: Couldn't go anywhere for a while.
Lucia: 然后这段时间在上海找了一个舞室
Lucia: During that time, I found a dance studio in Shanghai.
Lucia: 然后就是那会是吧
Lucia: And that was when...
Jake: 是是在一个小区还是
Jake: Was it in a community, or...?
Lucia: 本来本来想学一下
Lucia: I originally wanted to learn...
Jake: 不是小区不能出
Jake: Couldn't leave the community.
Lucia: 是小区就是他
Lucia: If it's the community, it's him.
Lucia: 是舞房的话
Lucia: If it's the dance studio,
Lucia: 一般他都购物中心里面
Lucia: he usually goes to the shopping center.
Jake: 哦这样子OK
Jake: Oh, I see. OK.
Lucia: 然后就是我
Lucia: And then there's me.
Lucia: 我本来想去试一下学那个
Lucia: I originally wanted to try to learn that.
Lucia: 我当时报了一个splash
Lucia: I signed up for a splash class at that time.
Jake: 哎呀你这也没电了
Jake: Oh no, your battery's dead.
Lucia: 然后跳了两三节之后我发现不行
Lucia: After dancing for two or three sessions, I realized it wasn't working.
Lucia: 我跳不动
Lucia: I couldn't keep up.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 然后我就放弃了
Lucia: So I gave up.
Katrina:  我们我报的那个hip Hop班
Katrina: I signed up for that hip-hop class.
Katrina:  我是报通卡
Katrina: I got the all-access pass.
Katrina:  就是什么班都能跳
Katrina: So I could attend any class.
Katrina:  然后他这黑怕
Katrina: And for hip-hop,
Katrina:  他是基本不教那种片段舞
Katrina: they basically don't teach segments of dances.
Katrina:  就是只练基本功
Katrina: They only practice fundamentals.
Lucia: 那那很好
Lucia: That's great.
Katrina:  对有一点点但是会有一点点枯燥
Katrina: Yeah, but it can be a bit boring.
Katrina:  然后像爵士这种
Katrina: Unlike jazz,
Alice: 你的线呢宝
Alice: Where's your charger, babe?
Lucia: 我没学过爵士
Lucia: I haven't learned jazz.
Jake: 没电了就是单纯的没电插上
Jake: It's just that the battery's dead. Plug it in.
Lucia: 虽然我觉得很好看
Lucia: Even though I think it's beautiful.
Lucia: 但是我感觉我自己好像不是很能跳出那个感觉就是hi-pop比较适合我
Lucia: But I feel like I can't really dance it well. Hip-hop suits me better.
Katrina:  但是你你学这种的
Katrina: But you know, learning this,
Katrina:  其实还挺适合你跳的因为我觉得你还挺柔的
Katrina: it actually suits you because you're quite flexible.
Lucia: 真的吗谢谢
Lucia: Really? Thank you!
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 啊这真的好好看
Lucia: Ah, this is really beautiful.
Tasha: blue 蓝牙连接失败
Tasha: Blue, Bluetooth connection failed.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 好好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 长沙工资比苏州低
Lucia: Wages in Changsha are lower than in Suzhou.
Katrina:  就我一个同学找工作呢
Katrina: I have a classmate looking for a job.
Katrina:  他他一个offer在长沙一个在苏州
Katrina: He has one offer in Changsha and one in Suzhou.
Katrina:  他在纠结去哪
Katrina: He's struggling to choose.
Katrina:  对苏州那是要比长沙
Katrina: Yeah, Suzhou is better than Changsha.
Katrina:  他你知道他今年考研
Katrina: Did you know he is taking the graduate exam this year?
Katrina:  他他出了分数以后
Katrina: After he got the scores
Katrina:  他觉得自己稳考不上你知道吗
Katrina: He thought he definitely wouldn't pass, you know
Katrina:  结果
Katrina: But
Katrina:  今年同济的分数比去年低了三四十分
Katrina: This year, Tongji's scores were thirty or forty points lower than last year
Lucia: 然后他考上了
Lucia: And then he got in
Katrina:  他其实考上了
Katrina: He actually got in
Katrina:  但是他没有准备一点的复试
Katrina: But he didn't prepare for the interview at all
Katrina:  他直接找工作去了
Katrina: He just went to find a job directly
Katrina:  我靠今年真的很奇怪
Katrina: I swear this year is really weird
Jake: 那他后来准备了吗
Jake: Did he prepare later?
Katrina:  没准备复试
Katrina: Didn't prepare for the interview
Katrina:  他直接没去复试他就找工作去了
Katrina: He didn't go to the interview, he just went to find a job
Lucia: 啊那有点可惜
Lucia: Ah, that's a bit of a pity
Katrina:  有点烦
Katrina: Kind of annoying
Lucia: 他应该就是
Lucia: He should've
Lucia: 反正已经拿到复试机会了
Lucia: Anyway, he already got the interview opportunity
Lucia: 就去卡拉OK一下
Lucia: Just go sing karaoke or something
Katrina:  但是但是他他出那个对好像同济
Katrina: But, but he, he, right, like Tongji
Lucia: 说不定就是我了
Lucia: Maybe it's me
Jake: 对啊卡拉OK
Jake: Yeah, karaoke
Jake: 对一会修硕就卡拉OK回来了
Jake: Yeah, Shure will be back from karaoke later
Katrina:  还同济还不怎么筛人呢
Katrina: And Tongji doesn't really filter people out
Lucia: 咳
Lucia: Cough
Tasha: 重新开了要读秒吗
Tasha: Restart the timer?
Jake: 要要
Jake: Yes, yes
Alice: 我们今天是不是还没读秒
Alice: Didn't we start the timer today?
Tasha:  没读
Tasha: Didn't start
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Katrina:  先确定一下哦还有分花写名字
Katrina: Let's confirm first, oh, and divide the flowers and write names
Katrina:  确实特别是这种有花苞的可以记录一下
Katrina: Especially the ones with buds, make sure to record
Jake: 来
Jake: Come
Jake: 看时间
Jake: Check the time
Katrina:  谁要打游戏吗看比赛吗
Katrina: Anyone want to play games or watch matches?
Katrina:  我有个舍友天天看
Katrina: I have a roommate who watches every day
Tasha:  真的吗对
Tasha: Really? Yeah
Katrina:  对他
Katrina: Yeah, he
Katrina:  他会因为那些选手没打好而气得半死
Katrina: He gets so mad when the players don't play well
Tasha:  是的
Tasha: I know, right
Katrina:  这这他在宿舍又哭又笑的
Katrina: He's in the dorm crying and laughing
Katrina:  看总决赛的时候他看的
Katrina: Watching the finals, he was so into it
Tasha:  哦他看的难道是LCK决赛
Tasha: Oh, is he watching the LCK finals?
Jake: 啊哈这么带劲
Jake: Haha, that's exciting.
Katrina:  难道是他就看英雄联盟
Katrina: Is he just watching League of Legends?
Tasha:  还是LPL吗
Tasha: Or is it the LPL?
Katrina:  我不知道
Katrina: I don't know.
Katrina:  他看好多
Katrina: He watches a lot.
Katrina:  对LPL他他都看
Katrina: Yeah, he watches all the LPL games.
Alice: 你最喜欢谁啊
Alice: Who's your favorite?
Tasha:  我最喜欢的就是这支队伍的这个选手
Tasha: My favorite is this player from that team.
Alice: 这叫啥
Alice: What's the name?
Tasha:  他叫Cherry
Tasha: His name is Cherry.
Katrina:  他看他喜欢
Katrina: He watches, he likes...
Katrina:  那叫什么小花生
Katrina: What's his name, Peanut?
Katrina:  韩国的那个
Katrina: The Korean one.
Katrina:  小花生
Katrina: Peanut.
Tasha:  enough
Tasha: Enough.
Katrina:  他叫他对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, that's him.
Katrina:  好像是他
Katrina: Seems like it's him.
Tasha:  哈哈哈我知道
Tasha: Haha, I know.
Katrina:  就是那个单眼皮那个他
Katrina: The guy with the single eyelid, yeah, him.
Tasha:  特别帅的打野
Tasha: The really handsome jungler.
Katrina:  他就说他长得挺帅的
Katrina: He always says he's really good-looking.
Tasha:  Tina和我喜欢的Chovy
Tasha: Tina and I like Chovy.
Tasha:  昨去年是一支队伍的
Tasha: Last year they were in the same team.
Tasha:  然后今年他们全部都转队了
Tasha: And this year they've all switched teams.
Lucia: 观赏一下
Lucia: Let's watch.
Alice: 我好像看到过很多次这个名字
Alice: I think I've seen that name many times.
Tasha:  Faker
Tasha: Faker.
Alice: 嗯看什么顶级的
Alice: Hmm, watching top-tier stuff?
Katrina:  啊我也是
Katrina: Ah, me too.
Katrina:  Faker不是那个最有名的
Katrina: Isn't Faker the most famous one?
Tasha:  他就是嗯
Tasha: He is, yeah.
Alice: 顶级打野吗
Alice: A top-tier jungler?
Tasha:  顶级中单
Tasha: A top-tier mid laner.
Tasha:  他怎么说呢
Tasha: How should I put it...
Alice: 顶级中单
Alice: A top-tier mid laner.
Tasha:  他特别厉害
Tasha: He's really amazing.
Tasha:  怎么说他现在就是已经30岁了
Tasha: How to say, he's already 30 years old.
Tasha:  一般选手在25岁就要退役了
Tasha: Usually players retire at 25.
Tasha:  就是因为反应速度跟不上
Tasha: Because their reaction speed can't keep up.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm
Tasha:  然后他在30岁这年
Tasha: Then when he turned 30
Tasha:  还拿了一个世界总冠军
Tasha: He won another world championship
Tasha:  哇哦对
Tasha: Wow, yeah
Lucia: 喔哦
Lucia: Wow
Tasha:  然后他人身上已经拿过三次冠军
Tasha: So he's won three championships before
Tasha:  这是第四次冠军
Tasha: This is his fourth championship
Tasha:  很多人打了十年都没有过一次冠军
Tasha: Many people play for ten years without ever winning one championship
Tasha:  对而且他是出道级巅峰吧
Tasha: Yeah, and he was at his peak from the start
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: That's amazing
Tasha:  好像是15岁
Tasha: He started at 15
Tasha:  然后高中
Tasha: And in high school
Tasha:  上初中还是上高中
Tasha: Was it middle school or high school
Tasha:  的时候偶然间被发现了
Tasha: When he was discovered by chance
Tasha:  然后就然后就被选中了
Tasha: And then he got selected
Tasha:  然后就打比赛
Tasha: And then he started competing
Tasha:  然后一打比赛
Tasha: And in his first match
Tasha:  就把当时的顶级中单
Tasha: He took down the top mid laner one-on-one
Tasha:  给一对一的杀掉了
Tasha: Defeated him in a one-on-one
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's incredible
Tasha:  然后就一战成名
Tasha: And then he became famous overnight
Jake: 好过分啊
Jake: That's so unfair
Jake: 哈哈哈对
Jake: Haha, yeah
Tasha:  对
Tasha: Yeah
Lucia: 好厉害啊
Lucia: That's amazing
Jake: 强到过分
Jake: Too strong
Jake: 就是就是
Jake: Exactly
Tasha:  就是一出道就强到过分
Tasha: He was insanely strong from the start
Tasha:  并且一直强了这么多年
Tasha: And has been strong for so many years
Katrina:  昨天那个写名字的
Katrina: The one who wrote the name yesterday
Katrina:  哦在这
Katrina: Oh, it's here
Tasha:  而且他就是从来不买皮肤
Tasha: And he never buys skins
Tasha:  就是不提倡大家买皮肤
Tasha: He doesn't encourage buying skins
Tasha:  所以他在比赛还是平时的打
Tasha: So whether in matches or just playing
Tasha:  打游戏就只用原皮
Tasha: He only uses the default skin
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈好有意思
Alice: Hahaha, so interesting
Tasha:  哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Katrina:  我纯技术虐
Katrina: I rely purely on skill
Tasha:  啊对
Tasha: Yeah, exactly
Tasha:  好像说韩国90%的人只要玩英雄联盟
Tasha: I heard that in Korea, 90% of people who play League of Legends
Tasha:  都是他的粉丝
Tasha: They're all his fans.
Jake: 剩下10%嫉妒他是吗呵
Jake: The remaining 10% are just jealous of him, right? Haha.
Tasha:  男粉啊什么男生嫉妒他
Tasha: Male fans, yeah, what guys are jealous of him.
Tasha:  女生都很喜欢他
Tasha: Girls really like him.
Katrina:  去拿一支笔下来
Katrina: Go grab a pen.
Tasha:  而且保持着极高的职业素养
Tasha: And he maintains an incredibly high professional standard.
Tasha:  到现在都没有谈过一场恋爱
Tasha: He hasn't even been in a relationship yet.
Tasha:  哇为就是为游戏奉献人生的感觉
Tasha: Wow, it's like he's dedicated his life to the game.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Tasha:  就直接打总决赛了都
Tasha: We're directly into the finals now.
Tasha:  他可能是队伍的一个核心大脑
Tasha: He might be the core strategist of the team.
Tasha:  就那种偏指挥的
Tasha: Like the one who commands.
Tasha:  还有偏运营的都归他啊
Tasha: And also manages operations, all under his control.
Alice: 他长哪个样子
Alice: What does he look like?
Tasha:  这是他们队的ad
Tasha: This is their AD.
Tasha:  因为现在在选ad位
Tasha: Because they're selecting the AD role now.
Tasha:  这个人长得是不是有点像杨戬
Tasha: Doesn't this guy look a bit like Yang Jian?
Tasha:  哈哈哈我当时看的时候
Tasha: Haha, when I was watching, I thought...
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  你们写一下名字
Katrina: Write down the names.
Tasha:  就是那个宝莲灯里面的那个三眼狼
Tasha: Like the three-eyed wolf from the Lotus Lantern.
Katrina:  就选花吗
Katrina: Should we just choose flowers?
Alice: 我给你写吧还是你写
Alice: Should I write it for you or you do it?
Katrina:  选这个吧
Katrina: Let's choose this one.
Alice: ok这是我
Alice: Okay, this is mine.
Alice: 给你写啥
Alice: What should I write for you?
Tasha:  给我画个翅膀就行
Tasha: Just draw me some wings.
Alice: 天呐我的翅膀多丑
Alice: Oh no, my wings look awful.
Tasha:  那个peanut
Tasha: That peanut...
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Tasha:  给你们看看LCK美男
Tasha: Let me show you the handsome guys of LCK.
Katrina:  要给他们晒太
Katrina: Need to show them too.
Alice: 完了
Alice: Oh no.
Alice: 啊怎么办
Alice: What should we do?
Katrina:  你们稍微挑一下
Katrina: Just pick one carefully.
Alice: 怎么办哈哈哈
Alice: What should we do? Hahaha.
Tasha:  就这样吧
Tasha: Let's just go with this.
Lucia: 哎挺可爱的
Lucia: Aw, it's pretty cute.
Tasha:  这个就是peanut
Tasha: This is peanut.
Alice: 给你加个爱心好了
Alice: Let me add a heart for you.
Tasha:  就是那个小花生
Tasha: It's that little peanut.
Katrina:  看看我看看是不是他
Katrina: Let me see if it's him.
Katrina:  抖音经常发的那个男人
Katrina: The guy who often posts on TikTok.
Tasha:  啊哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina:  是他
Katrina: It's him.
Tasha:  我知道
Tasha: I know.
Tasha:  很帅啦
Tasha: He's very handsome.
Katrina:  我给你看他的抖音
Katrina: I'll show you his TikTok.
Katrina:  他每天都发这些的
Katrina: He posts these every day.
Lucia: 确实很帅啊
Lucia: He really is handsome.
Tasha:  真的很帅的
Tasha: He's really handsome.
Lucia: 确实挺帅的
Lucia: He is pretty handsome.
Katrina:  他是是挺帅的
Katrina: He is quite handsome.
Tasha:  嗯是呃
Tasha: Yeah, he is.
Tasha:  这种辅助型打野的代表了啊
Tasha: He's a representative of support-type junglers.
Tasha:  这个就是我喜欢的英雄
Tasha: This is the type of hero I like.
Jake: 这就是补刀不漏兵吗
Jake: Is this last-hitting without missing any minions?
Tasha:  是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake: 是的哈哈哈
Jake: Yes, haha.
Tasha:  一刀不漏呵呵
Tasha: Not missing a single hit, haha.
Katrina:  他的抖音
Katrina: His TikTok.
Katrina:  每天剪他的
Katrina: He edits his videos every day.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha:  他真的很可爱了
Tasha: He's really cute.
Katrina:  哎对他就每天说
Katrina: Yeah, he says every day.
Katrina:  你知道他有多可爱吗
Katrina: Do you know how cute he is?
Katrina:  我说谁都给你看
Katrina: I tell everyone to watch him.
Katrina:  笑死
Katrina: So funny.
Tasha:  他谁啊好丑啊哈哈
Tasha: Who is he? So ugly, haha.
Tasha:  哎这个是国内选手
Tasha: Oh, this is a domestic player.
Lucia: 所以这是个混剪
Lucia: So this is a montage.
Lucia: 我以为是他的个人像呢
Lucia: I thought it was his personal one.
Tasha:  这个也是国内选手
Tasha: This one is also a domestic player.
Alice: 为什么我感觉他又长得有点像那个谁
Alice: Why do I feel like he looks a bit like that guy?
Tasha:  刘青松
Tasha: Liu Qingsong.
Alice: 不认识是那个
Alice: I don't know him, the other one.
Alice: 王
Alice: Wang.
Tasha:  不知道他已经算是
Tasha: I don't know, he's already considered.
Tasha:  国内就中国队的第一美男了
Tasha: The most handsome guy in the Chinese team.
Alice: 刚刚那个长得好像那个
Alice: The previous one looked like that guy.
Alice: 谁呀
Alice: Who is it?
Alice: 想不起来我难受
Alice: I can't remember, it's bothering me.
Tasha:  这些我都不喜欢
Tasha: I don't like any of these.
Tasha:  都很一般哈哈哈
Tasha: They're all pretty average, haha.
Jake: 好开点外卖吧
Jake: Alright, let's order some takeout.
Alice: 王王什么王
Alice: Wang, Wang what?
Jake: 点点外卖吧
Jake: Let's order some takeout.
Lucia:  暂存
Lucia: Save it.
Tasha:  and我觉得
Tasha: And I think...
Alice: 王什么
Alice: Wang what?
Alice: 没事王什么来着
Alice: Never mind, Wang what?
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Tasha:  怎么没了
Tasha: Why is it gone?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice: 取消了
Alice: It's canceled.
Katrina:  点外卖还是啥
Katrina: Ordering takeout or what?
Jake: 点外卖
Jake: Order takeout.
Katrina:  你们挑一下自己的花哟
Katrina: You guys pick your flowers.
Tasha:  这款我        很喜欢
Tasha: I really like this one.
Jake: 挑花
Jake: Pick flowers.
Jake: 要不等修硕来
Jake: How about we wait for Shure?
Jake: 我们先把这一端给结了就结束吧
Jake: Let's finish this end first and then be done.
Jake: 上午上午
Jake: Morning, morning.
Alice: 点了是吗
Alice: Did you order?
Jake: 就这样还没有点
Jake: Not yet.
Alice: 不是啊对啊
Alice: No, yeah.
Jake: 就是这个
Jake: It's this one.
Lucia: 我们好像
Lucia: It seems like we...
Jake: 关掉关掉关掉
Jake: Turn it off, turn it off, turn it off.
Alice: 这就是把这个点掉
Alice: Just turn this off.
Katrina:  还有我们的舞蹈
Katrina: And our dance.
Tasha:  什么点掉这个
Tasha: What do you mean turn this off?
Alice: 就关掉要开始关了是吗对
Alice: Just turn it off, starting to turn it off, right.
Tasha:  关掉关掉干嘛好
Tasha: Turn it off, turn it off, okay.
Jake: 对关掉
Jake: Yes, turn it off.
Katrina:  哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Alice: 关掉结束了
Alice: Turn it off, it's done.
Katrina:  我都忘记泡我的种子了
Katrina: I forgot to soak my seeds.
Tasha:  好吧
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha:  我在面对以后的研究人员
Tasha: I'm looking forward to future researchers.
Katrina:  天呐感觉货到了那种
Katrina: Oh my gosh, feels like the goods have arrived.
Tasha:  我说我们在欣赏电竞美男
Tasha: I said we're admiring the handsome e-sports players.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice: 那就停了
Alice: Then let's stop.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina:  哦在这我的杯子
Katrina: Oh, here's my cup.
Lucia: 啊这是你的杯子吗OK OK
Lucia: Ah, is this your cup? OK, OK.
Katrina:  不是我要泡种子
Katrina: No, I need to soak seeds.
Lucia: complete
Lucia: Complete.
Lucia: 哦它还是在充电它现在恢复到了25%
Lucia: Oh, it's still charging. It's now back to 25%.
Jake:嗯好没关系
Jake: Mm, it's fine.
Tasha: 这项研究不是你一个人做吗
Tasha: Isn't this research you're doing alone?
Tasha: 怎么会有100多个人后来又去看呢
Tasha: How come over 100 people later came to see it?
Jake:就是给他们用
Jake: It's for them to use.
Katrina:  你这是开源
Katrina: You're open-sourcing it.
Katrina:  你这数据集是开源的是吗
Katrina: Your dataset is open-source, right?
Katrina:  那这开源
Katrina: Then open-source...
Katrina:  也得等你们这论文写完了才能开
Katrina: ...only after you finish writing the paper.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Mm, yes.
Katrina:  要不然会被
Katrina: Otherwise, it will be...
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  希望我以后也有说这种说这种的勇气
Katrina: I hope I have the courage to say that in the future.
Katrina:  你这个采
Katrina: Your collection...
Katrina:  这个采集数据集不是第一步吗
Katrina: Isn't collecting the dataset the first step?
Jake:是的是的第一计划
Jake: Yes, yes, the first plan.
Lucia: 第一计划是GPT的
Lucia: The first plan is GPT's.
Jake:对对是的
Jake: Yes, yes, it is.
Lucia: 就是有一个学术论文他的第一句话明显是GPT生成
Lucia: There's an academic paper where the first sentence is obviously generated by GPT.
Katrina:  yes然后什么我回答
Katrina: Yes, and then what, I responded...
Lucia: 而且那个是一个很好的刊
Lucia: And it was a very good journal.
Lucia: 好像
Lucia: It seems...
Jake:哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 应该是
Lucia: It should be.
Lucia: 那个是一个很好的刊了
Lucia: It was a very good journal.
Katrina:  发芽吧我的种子
Katrina: Sprout, my seeds.
Jake:我们这个领域他们太卷了就是
Jake: In our field, the competition is too intense.
Jake:一定要赶紧发不然就
Jake: We must publish quickly, otherwise...
Katrina:  但是你这采集数据集是第一步
Katrina: But collecting the dataset is just the first step.
Katrina:  那你不是还要搞模型啊啥的吗
Katrina: Don't you still have to work on the model and stuff?
Jake:模型别的数据都在训呢正在训
Jake: The model and other data are being trained right now.
Katrina:  我已经训好
Katrina: I've already trained it well.
Katrina:  到时候你把这个自己的数据导进去就行了
Katrina: You just need to import your own data into it when the time comes.
Jake:这个反应会在你们会出一些
Jake: This reaction will give you some...
Jake:这个标注确实时间比较长
Jake: This annotation does take quite a long time.
Katrina:  但但但是自己的数据集
Katrina: But... but... but with your own dataset...
Katrina:  丢进去不一定效果好
Katrina: Just throwing it in might not work well.
Katrina:  还要调调调
Katrina: It still needs some tweaking.
Jake:但是主要就是因为这个数据集第一个
Jake: But the main reason is that this dataset, first of all...
Katrina:  干吧
Katrina: Got it.
Jake:对是是这么说是他
Jake: Yes, that's right, that's what he said.
Jake:就就没人就没人比过
Jake: No one has compared it yet.
Jake:没人在上面跑过
Jake: No one has run it yet.
Jake:我们跑多少都行
Jake: We can run as much as we want.
Katrina:  啊就是因为你这数据自己新的
Katrina: Ah, it's because your data is new.
Katrina:  blue tooth connection lost
Katrina: blue tooth connection lost
Alice:为什么关了之后还这么慢
Alice: Why is it still so slow after turning it off?
Tasha: 你把VPN关了对
Tasha: Did you turn off the VPN?
Alice:也关了
Alice: Yes, I did.
Lucia: 我今天这个网也出了状况
Lucia: My internet also had issues today.
Alice:还是超级慢
Alice: It's still super slow.